[Music]
demi lovato
is making her voice heard the 28 year
old singer took to the 2020 billboard
music awards stage to deliver her
powerful new song commander-in-chief
the politically charged anthem takes a
firm stance against president donald
trump
calling him out for his response to
racial injustice
the coven 19 pandemic and more as demi
saying the song the word
vote appeared on the screen in big
letters it's a great way to inspire my
fans and get them ready for
for later and in hopes that it inspires
them to do something with their lives
and
you know make a change demi played the
piano something
she teased before her big night on her
instagram story
julia michaels who wrote the song with
demi spoke to e.t about their
collaboration
she just was like you know i really want
to talk about this topic it means a lot
to me and it means a lot to a lot of
people that are in the voting process
right now we wrote it in like
an hour and we were like all right well
that's it we did it
we cried a little bit we said what we
needed to say and now it's not in the
world
what's also out the official music video
which dropped
right after the
we'll be on show streets while you're
bunkering down
shortly after the release of commander
in chief demi clapped back at fans who
told her to keep her political views to
herself
responding on instagram saying i
literally
don't care if this ruins my career
demi has been making new music lately
the singer previously released her
single still have me
i don't have much
fans believe the song is about her
ex-fiance max eric
the pair split just two months after
their engagement
in september a source told et that it
was a tough decision
but debbie and max have decided to go
their separate ways
to focus on their respective careers
they have respect and love for one
another and will always cherish the time
they spent together